filmed by al-jazeera two weeks ago this
is believed to be the plane that's
crashed the c-130 Hercules is the
biggest fire fighting plane used by
Australia's Rural Fire Service it's
capable of dumping fifteen thousand
litres of water or retardant each flight
three American crew members were onboard
contractors from a u.s. aerial
firefighting company all are believed to
have died it's impacted heavily with the
ground and initial reports are that
there was a large fireball associated
with the impact of the plane as it hit
the ground we've got a number of
firefighters and a number of crew that
are in the area and working to contain
and work around the fire it is still an
active fire ground and and it did take
some time with the use of ground crews
and a number of aerial surveillance
platforms to try and locate the wreckage
of the plane today is a reminder of how
every single person who is defending
life and property is at risk because of
the dangerous circumstances in the
firefighting community around New South
Wales Australia in the world is very
tight needed I know many people have
been impacted rain across southeastern
Australia had recently dampened the
country's unprecedented bush fires but
on Thursday very hot very windy
conditions returned and dozens of new
fires flared up bush fires near the
capital Canberra forced the complete
closure of its Airport people living
nearby were told to evacuate until the
fires got so bad that fleeing became
more dangerous than staying put after a
terrible month it had seemed Australia's
fires were easing Thursday's heat and
wind across New South Wales shows how
quickly they can return and the loss of
a plane and three lives how quickly
tragedy can strike Andrew Thomas al
Jazeera Sydney Neil baby is a former
chief executive of Victoria's Country
Fire Authority he joins us now via Skype
from Sydney Neil what was this this
aircraft a bit a big aircraft what was
it doing at the time that it crashed hi
it's a c-130 Hercules aircraft so all
large engines and as your broadcaster
said earlier can take up to 15,000
liters of water over time it's been with
the fire services for a number of years
now Colson aviation runs the service
this is a very sad occasion indeed and
as Andrew Thomas was was saying just a
few moments ago that the rain that
southeastern Australia had experienced
had had kind of given some relief for a
while it appears though that the worst
is not yet over it's a false sense of
security people don't understand that in
Victoria the fire season usually starts
about the time of the Australian Open we
only started yesterday so we're now
looking for Victoria's coming into a
normal fire season after having an or
end us two months beforehand and at the
same time the New South Wales fires are
normally out by now and we can use wise
New South Wales the aerial appliances
and sprues that's not going to happen
because New South Wales still has
significant fires to fight a [ __ ] to
take months if they can look and draw
the rain was helpful but it didn't do
anything to containing the major fires
we have so basically just as Victoria
enters it's its traditional bushfire
season you've got all of these these
fires right along the eastern seaboard
what about Queensland at the moment
Queensland still has a couple of fires
remaining from the earlier on this year
when they had a very early fire season
but with some unfortunately with the way
the weather patterns are at the moment
with climate changing the way it is
anything will be coming into the monsoon
season so they had gone from fires to
monsoon and the volunteers that normally
look after those sorts of incidents
they're going to be very very tired so
how does some New South Wales and
Victoria
then if resources are that stretched how
do they they cope with what's to come
well they using technology like the
planes that were being seen and they're
utilizing their staff and some hard
decisions have to be made as to which
files you let run on which size you can
contain the fire around Canberra was a
perfect example of what can happen in a
very short time it started yesterday
burned 508 hectares of land closed the
nation's major airport and they only
happened yesterday so if we get the
lightning strikes that they're being
predicted so we'll get under storms with
bright lightning we're going to have
more fires starting over the next month
Neil I've a feeling we're gonna be
talking a lot more in the next few weeks
unfortunately for the moment many thanks
indeed for being with us once again Neil
baby there former chief executive of
Victorious
yep what you can do yeah he's since some
of that rain or with an end of talking
about it was absolutely their idea Neil
many thanks indeed